[Music]
Disney's Andy Mac is definitely pushing
the envelope with his controversial
storyline and characters but did you
know there are some dark secrets Disney
doesn't want you to know about we've got
10 juicy tidbits for you right here you
won't believe what Disney did on number
one if you like Andy Mac as much as we
do be sure to subscribe to the things
channel for more awesome videos about
this super cool show and many others
like this video click the thumbs up
button
Disney pulled the show across Africa and
the Middle East
due to the gay storyline in season 2 of
Andy Mac 13 year old Cyrus Goodman
played by Joshua Rush develops feelings
for his friend Jonah most American fans
are excited about this progressive new
ground Disney is trending on but in
other countries the show has been banned
due to its content about LGBTQ
storylines in Africa something called
the Kenyan Film classification Board
issued a statement saying TV stations
were prohibited from airing contents
that is quote likely to influence
children's perceptions negatively on the
institution of family the board said
that they were receiving a number of
public complaints so they said in a
Facebook post that the board has a duty
to protect children from exposure to
harmful film and television content the
board even pressured the entertainment
company MultiChoice into fooling seven
cartoons from the air because of what
they called retro aggressive and bizarre
messages intended to promote the LGBT
agenda did you know homosexuality is a
crime in Kenya we think that's pretty
bizarre and Kenya is not the only
country to have the show pulled from the
air due to some major pressure from
homophobes Disney caves and fooled Andy
Mac from about 50 countries across
sub-saharan Africa and the Middle East
jeez lighten up guys backlash in the
United States this gay storyline in Andy
Mac is also getting blasted from
conservatives here in the United States
the puritanical group 1 Million Moms
posits girdle in a bunch about Cyrus
coming out as gay and crushing on his
friend Jonah while LGBTQ rights
advocates are praising Disney for their
all-inclusive contents 1 million
is launching a petition calling for a
boycott of the Disney Channel until they
produce what they are calling more
family-friendly shows yeah like we need
another Air Bud movie this new content
is a pretty big step for Disney
according to rumours Disney has had a
secret long-running ban against anything
LGBTQ but it's a new dawn and Disney
doesn't want to be left behind
however this hate group called 1 Million
Moms is not okay with Disney's new
progressive stance they've had a problem
with other shows too these zealots have
been clutching their pearls over Ellen
DeGeneres Toys R Us and even the Muppets
this group of self-appointed killjoys
are actually made up of about 3,700
mostly mailed Twitter followers despite
them calling themselves 1 Million Moms
homophobic much um why are grown men
watching the Disney Channel we think
these creepy old dudes need a new hobby
seriously stop staring at young boys on
the TV some parents aren't too keen on
the unplanned teen pregnancy part in
Angie Mac and his older sister vex drops
the bombshell that she's actually andis
mom and that Andy has been raised by her
grandmother all along whoa what a
shocking plot twists while we think it's
cooled at Disney's including stories
about children from all walks of life
some parents are freaking out one parent
said she was absolutely disgusted with
the plotline of the show then she
pretended to support diversity within
Disney Channel shows but bashed Andy Mac
for introducing the concept of unplanned
pregnancy this parent threw a hissy fit
about backs lying about being Andy's
sister she said she was very
uncomfortable letting her children watch
the show claiming her own eight-year-old
daughter asked her if she was really her
sister that's kind of funny and so what
if kids are exposed to different types
of family dynamics that eight-year-old
just might go to school with a child who
is living with that same situation
what's this mom gonna do then ban the
child this girl needs to take a chill
pill and realize that not all families
are alike and that's okay that's what
diversity is don't worry mom your
eight-year-old can teach you all about
it this show may have inadvertently
endorsed bullying and peer pressure
jumping on the attack
and eMac bandwagon another parents spoke
out against the show saying it teaches
kids for values according to this
uptight parent the show glorifies sexist
irresponsible behavior and disrespect of
authority right like blindly following
Authority is a good thing that didn't
work out so well for Nazi Germany did
it's we disagree with this parent we
think a show that encourages kids to
think for themselves is a good thing if
no one ever challenged Authority when
they disagreed with it slavery would
still be a thing and women wouldn't be
allowed to vote we say rock on little
rebels and then the parent went on to
complain about the show teaching kids to
give in to peer pressure
he said Andy and Cyrus get talked into
things that they don't want to do that
may get them into trouble and the kicker
is when this parent said that the
characters of the show had the audacity
to demand respect
Camas crazy but we believe all people
should be respected regardless of their
age over where they come from this
parent sure had a lot of time on his
hands to learn so much about this show
he can't stand still we're sure Disney
doesn't want you reading his review
Disney needed Andy Mac to save them from
plummeting ratings there might be a
legit reason the Disney Channel is
tackling newer more controversial
subject matter according to nielsen info
viewership is down 18 percent for kids
from ages 2 to 11 since 2016 while its
competition Nickelodeon is staying
pretty solid Disney stockholders started
putting pressure on the network to find
a new hit show Disney's chief executive
Robert Iger blamed lower ratings on
Netflix and what he called a bit of an
off cycle at the Disney Channel he said
he wanted to step in a bold new
direction with a new show and Andy Mack
seemed like the right move it is very
bold and fresh but will this show
because I fraps Disney needs to please
their shareholders and compete with
Nickelodeon and Netflix only time and
fans will tell Disney consulted with the
National Campaign to Prevent teen
unplanned pregnancy and the National
Center on adoption and permanency these
organizations advised Disney to
emphasize taking responsibility for
choices and the enormous
responsibilities of a parent of guardian
pretty intense stuff Disney must have
been desperate to go from their usual
snappy sing song shows to the
complicated trials and struggles of
unplanned teen pregnancy one of the show
creators used to write for Sex in the
City so if you're a formerly conserve
network and you want to write a hit show
that appeals to 13 year olds who would
you pick to write it you might be
surprised to find out who Disney hired
as the show creator for Andy Mack it's
none other than the provocative writer
for the racy risque show Sex in the City
not exactly what you had in mind for a
tween show on the Disney Channel right
well Tara Minsky already bailed the
Disney Channel out in 2001 with the hit
show Lizzie McGuire Disney enjoyed a
long run of successful shows like Lizzie
McGuire for quite a while but with the
shareholders turning up the heat on the
network
they came calling to Terri Minsky again
for a new idea it's incredible that's
someone with a talent for writing about
the steamy encounters between
30-something women and their male
counterparts could tone it down and
write for the Disney Channel well hey
anything's possible as long as she
leaves Samantha out of this kid-friendly
show we all know what that lady's been
up to and it's not appropriate for young
viewers hide your eyes kids one thing's
for sure
Terri Minsky seems to know what she's
doing the fans love Andy Mack Cyrus is
an actually Disney's first gay character
this is more of a fun fact rather than a
dark secret but did you know Cyrus is an
actually Disney's first gay character
while Cyrus's storyline is new to Disney
the first gay characters were actually
featured in an episode of the Disney XD
animated series star versus the forces
of evil in this episode two men are
kissing in the crowd at a concert
it looks like Disney dip their toe into
the lgbtq pool to test the waters before
introducing a tween who is coming out to
his friends and coming to terms with his
own sexuality wow they really dove in
headfirst with Angie Mac and we are glad
they did it's nice to see these in mouth
shared media execs evolving to include
everyone's stories not just the ones of
cisgender typical teenagers with the
same problems like someone has a concert
and is plagued with a huge pimple
oh no that story is so played out even a
collodion introduced a same-sex married
couples in their animated comedy the
loud house everybody's doing it and it
makes for more interesting stories and
characters win-win right Disney maybe
with more of these shows all kids will
have the chance to see themselves
represented in the media we think that's
a good thing
way to go guys Joshua rush can't arm
wrestle are you guys ready for some
juicy
aasif the kind that blows your mind and
leaves you going no way for days are you
sure okay come closer here it is Joshua
rush has puny biceps the kid can't arm
wrestle to save his milk money in an
interview with twist magazine the Disney
star admits to being beaten by Peyton
Elizabeth
seven-year-old little brother at arm
wrestling in fact Joshua said he was the
only person to have never won an arm
wrestling match when the cast members
got obsessed with this battle of the
biceps you may see this guy at the gym
soon because he said he was definitely
not proud of this embarrassing fact
Peyton and Sophia always tie when they
go arm to arms and the true reigning
champion of these Angie Mac arm
wrestling marathons ask your angel
ladies and gentlemen that dude must
totally workout we just hope Joshua's
arm can recover in time for season two
and she might want to get some push-ups
in before the next round of arm
wrestling with his castmates
airheads candy with bands from the set
in an interview Peyton Elizabeth we
shared a story about how she thought she
was done filming her scenes for the day
so she went on a candy run with asher
angel her treat of choice airheads
particularly the blue ones Peyton said
she was enjoying her sugary snack with
Asher when they told her she needed to
go back on set to film another scene she
went to the makeup trailer and
discovered that her whole mouth was
bright blue she was laughing pretty hard
about it but the executive producers
didn't think it was funny we don't know
how long it took Peyton to get rid of
the blue tongue but in this business
time is money
after that Joshua Rush said that
airheads candy along with any other
candy that might change the color of
your mouth were officially banned from
the set bummer
what do you guys think would Annie's
blue tongue have been too distracting to
focus on the show or do you think she
really blew it get it's blue alright
nevermind we hope they are still able to
enjoy many other kinds of non-staining
sweets on set we wouldn't want the cast
feeling blue ah yes we do love a good
play on words
Disney has its stars under tight control
during an interview Joshua rush was
talking about how much he loved shooting
the show in Utah because of all the snow
and winter sports but then he said
something that caught our attention he
said he's not allowed to do any of those
winter sports now we
to ask why so we dug a little deeper
into the restrictions placed on Disney
stars once they are under contract with
the mouse ear giant and we discovered
something pretty startling Disney
contracts are really strict like super
strict in one particular section called
the morals clause Disney can see what
I'll data in their shows if they
participate in any event that creates
what they call disrepute or scandal for
the company and there is another even
more disturbing clause in these
contracts it deals with disability
according to E online the wording of
this clause generally states that if an
artist is disabled in any way for any
reason Disney can terminate the stars
contract and even seek compensation for
losses
yikes can you imagine being badly
injured in a skiing accident and then
waking up to a lawsuit from the creators
of Mickey Mouse talk about your bad days
we can see why Joshua is steering clear
of winter sports for now is it worth it
what do you think and that's it for 10
dark secrets in an t-mac Disney doesn't
want you to know be sure to check out
our other videos on the things Channel
about all things Disney thanks for
watching
[Music]